you have anything to say it looks
delicious I don't know what I'm talking
about yours that's not yours oh that's
funny
[Music]
have you ever created a frittata from
scratch I don't know what a frittata is
on these cards you'll find a base for
taught a recipe but then it's up to you
to flavor your frittata in a snap okay
yeah this is a situation because I
thought this was a frittata at the end
you'll taste tests and rate each other
we're gonna be using these at muffington
uh-huh and the recipe starts with 4 eggs
I am vegetarian yeah I'm gonna use
avocado spinach can't go wrong with
sausage are you gonna put different
kinds of meat or yeah no conflicting
meats like I would mention of it I
thought you were gonna put them Flik do
you like chillies no go for it I don't
want for us you can kind of do whatever
you want you can't really go wrong it
can be weird to cook eggs at night but
not if you do a frittata yeah it sounds
fancy yeah Tata
lexer Clopton ease it preheat the oven
to yes actually that's really young 375
yeah
how do you time preheating the oven has
hit 375 so 12 to 15 minutes I can
already smell the strip
this has gotten oh yeah wow it's
actually really delicious yeah that's
good
I would eat this for breakfast lunch or
dinner let's do a little shopping yeah I
want to try mine this is really tasty
we'll call it a time that's called aside
okay do you do that snap thing again
didn't work this time there's nothing on
the table where's dessert where's
dessert